bonjour à tous je vais commencer par
vous parler d'einstein
vous connaissez tous einstein c'est tout
ce que c'est un génie
d'après vous quel a été le parcours
scolaire d'einstein brillant talentueux
pas du tout einstein avait tous les
critères des trains enfants en échec
scolaire
il était dyslexique et il a eu du mal à
parler avant l'âge de 9 ans ses parents
étaient très inquiets pour lui et la
plupart de ses professeurs pensa qu'il
n'arriverait à rien puisque cerise sur
le gâteau einstein était un rebelle et
il avait du mal avec l'ordre établi
donc manifestement on voit bien que cet
enfant qui était considéré comme ayant
des problèmes et s'est finalement avéré
être un génie vient einstein n'est pas
le seul dans ce cas là il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont aujourd'hui en échec
scolaire ou des adultes qui se
retrouvent dans des situations d'échec
de dépression ou d'addiction qui sont en
fait des enfants ou des adultes qui ont
des talents ou des formes d'intelligence
qui ne rentrent pas forcément dans les
codes et les critères du système
éducatif tel qu'il est fait aujourd'hui
et qui pourtant ne demande qu'une chose
c'est de pouvoir être exploitée pour
imager tout ça je vais prendre une
citation d'einstein encore une fois qui
est tout le monde a du génie mais si
vous jugez un poisson à sa capacité à
grimper à un arbre il pensera toute sa
vie qu'il est stupide
alors là je vais faire appel à votre
imagination ce que je n'ai pas de slide
donc je vais vous demander à tous
d'imaginer un arbre celui que vous
voulez en bas de cet art vous allez
imaginer un poisson quand on est un
poisson et qu'on nous demande de grimper
un arbre pour réussir notre vie on a
trois façons de gérer ça
la première option on va dire c'est
celle qu'a pris einstein
je suis un petit poisson joie cet arbre
et je me dis c'est pas fait pour moi
j'ai pas les capacités pour grimper à
l'arbre par contre je sais que un
poisson
une fois qu'il est dans l'eau il peut
s'exprimer comme il veut et si je vais
dans l'eau je vais pouvoir être le
meilleur mais ça c'est pas donné à tout
le monde c'est pas donné à tout le monde
d'avoir cette force de savoir ce
pourquoi en effet donc dans la plupart
des caves dans ce que j'ai observé
on a le cas numéro deux qu'un numéro 3
le cas numéro 2 on est un poisson un
arbre donc tout le monde nous dit pour
réussir dans la vie il faut avoir la
bonne réponse il faut faire les bonnes
études il faut choisir le bon métier et
là on aura bien réussi sa vie
donc ok ça c'est l'arbre moi je suis un
poisson ça va pas être facile mais je
vais essayer puisque je vois que tout le
monde y va
moi aussi donc je suis là donc imaginez
bien la fête imaginez bien tout ça vous
êtes là vous êtes le petit poisson vous
devez grimpé à l'arbre ça fait un petit
peu mal vos écailles se frotte contre
les corses c'est pas facile
vous aurez beau faire tous les efforts
que vous voulez il ya de grandes chances
que vous n'arriviez pas à monter en haut
de l'arbre
cette image en fait elle reflète la
façon dont le système éducatif
fonctionne aujourd'hui on demande à tous
les enfants quels qu'ils soient de
réussir les mêmes études
et pourtant on ne prend pas du tout en
compte leur qualité et leur talent de
départ fonctionner de cette manière va
mettre en échec
beaucoup d'enfants ou en situation
moyenne on va dire en tout cas et le
problème de tout ça c'est que beaucoup
d'enfants vont passer à côté totalement
de leur talent et ils vont même croire
qu'ils sont nuls
stupide et ça ça peut porter préjudice
même sur leur vie d'adulte la troisième
option
je suis un poisson je dois grimper en
haut de l'arbre et ça ça va être
c'était mon cas j'avais une très bonne
capacité d'adaptation
petit j'étais une enfant surdoué précoce
tout ce qu'on met entre les mains un
instrument de musique études j'ai été la
première en tout a priori j'avais un
destin tout tracé
une grande réussite m'attendais j'avais
réussi à monter en haut de l'arbre mieux
que tout le monde avant tout le monde
bizarrement à 18 ans c'est l'explosion
et c'est l'effet inverse
dix ans d'addiction c'est pas vraiment
ce qu'on m'avait dit donc là je commence
à chercher puisque tout le monde me dit
si tu as des addictions sais que tu as
un problème
donc je commence à chercher pourquoi
j'ai eu des addictions je regarde un
petit peu dans mon enfance j'ai pas eu
une enfance difficile au contraire et si
je regarde mon parcours scolaire il est
exemplaire est en fait en creusant je
tombe à un moment donné sur un livre sur
les adultes surdoué est là pour moi
c'est un déclic puisque ce livre est en
train de décrire exactement tout mon
mode de fonctionnement
il m'explique que si je me suis toujours
sentie différente parce que depuis petit
je dis souvent je me suis toujours senti
comme un rond dans un monde de cars et
j'avais l'impression de ne pas pouvoir
exprimer vraiment ce que j'étais je me
sentais différente mais personne n'avait
donné un mode d'emploi où on me disait
pas que je pouvais être ce que je suis
alors j'ai fait en sorte de me fondre
dans les moules et j'avais en plus une
capacité à capter assez rapidement ce
qu'on attendait de moi donc je me suis
fondu dans les attentes et dans les
cases qu'on m'avait proposé je les fais
même très bien donc je suis arrivé en
haut de mon arbre
mais jeudi il a en ce moment je
travaille beaucoup je travaille avec des
personnes dans le monde entier qui ont
extrêmement bien réussi leur vie
au delà de la moyenne et qui pourtant se
retrouvent eux aussi dans des formes
d'anxiété aiguë addiction dépression
pourquoi parce que de la même manière à
un moment donné ils ont tous réussi très
bien vu de l'extérieur ils ont une vie
parfaite mais pourtant sur le fond ils
sont pas heureux je vais reprendre
l'exemple de mon poisson si vous êtes un
poisson et vous êtes en haut d'un arbre
vous aurez bio vous aurez beau avoir la
plus belle vue qu'ils soient très bien
décorée
vous n'en est pas moins un poisson un
poisson il a besoin de quoi il a besoin
d'eau donc même si tout à l'air d'aller
très bien en apparence si vous manquer
d'eau il ya une part de vous qui va
commencer à vous dire que vous n'êtes
pas à votre place
donc vous allez commencer à vous sentir
mal ça va s'exprimer de façon différente
chez les uns chez les autres
si vous êtes quelqu'un qu'on appelle
surdoué ou hypersensible hyper actif
pour moi tout c'est le mot surdoué n'est
pas le mot que je préfère pas du tout
c'est juste des modes de fonctionnement
au niveau du cerveau qui sont différents
on retrouve chez les surdoués une
caractéristique et l'hypersensibilité
l'hypersensibilité parce que les
personnes qui sont hypersensibles ont
une densité de neurones sensoriels et
moteurs deux fois plus importante que
les autres ce qui fait qu'on a un
amplificateur au niveau des émotions
donc quand on est en haut de notre arbre
on a donné l'impression d'avoir tout
fait parfaitement mais que finalement on
est mal cet ampli qu'on a à l'intérieur
il va démultiplier cette sensation de
mal être
le problème c'est que vu de l'extérieur
comme tout le monde nous dit qu'on est
géniaux qu'on a l'air d'avoir tout bien
réussi on comprend pas du tout pourquoi
on s'emmêle les personnes dont je
m'occupe qui ont tous réussi vous
imaginez quelqu'un qui a tout réussi sa
vie professionnelle sa vie financière
il a réussi ce que tout le monde
voudrait il a toutes les belles
étiquettes de co2 fondateur de très
grosses entreprises etc
et pourtant il n'est pas heureux c'est
horrible vous allez vous plaindre à qui
vous allez voir vos amis qui vous envie
et leur dire que vous sentez pas très
bien dans votre peau
pas facile mon travail aujourd'hui c'est
d'aider toutes ces personnes à retrouver
leur place
donc si je suis là aujourd'hui devant
vous c'est pour vous dire qu'il est très
important il est fondamental d'écouter
ce petit baromètre à l'intérieur de vous
qui vous dit quand vous êtes à votre
place ou pas et ça c'est valable dans
les études
c'est valable dans la vie
professionnelle et c'est valable dans la
vie amoureuse parce que parfois on a
tendance à s'oublier à vouloir plaire à
vouloir prouver à vouloir montrer qu'on
est autre chose que ce qu'on a on fait
beaucoup d'efforts souvent alors que
finalement il est tellement plus simple
d'écouter ce qu'on a en nous ce qu'on a
envie de faire ce qui nous rend heureux
ce qui nous rend joyeux alors je vais
pas changer le système éducatif
aujourd'hui vous n'allez pas changer le
système non plus par contre il est
primordial de mettre dans votre vie des
activités qui vous rendent heureux qui
vous rendre joyeux qui vous rendent
fiers de vous si vous êtes un poisson
n'essayez pas mettez pas toute votre
énergie à grimper un arbre essayé de
rejoindre l'océan une marin et en
n'importe quoi mais vous deux
trouvez ce qui vous rend vraiment
heureux si vous avez la possibilité d'en
faire votre métier encore mieux
aujourd'hui contre toute attente eut
passé de élève surdoué donc avec un
avenir prometteur à priori ensuite j'ai
été à j'ai eu des addictions pendant dix
ans j'ai frôlé la mort par deux fois
tout le monde pensait que j'allais y
laisser ma peau et que j'allais très mal
finir et aujourd'hui je me retrouve à
faire un métier que personne d'autre ne
fait ce qu'on ait que trois au monde à
faire ça j'ai créé un métier à mon image
que j'adore que j'aime qui me rend
heureuse et ça pour moi c'est le plus
important
donc le message pour terminer surtout
n'essayez pas d'être comme les autres ne
gobez pas vos différences soyez vous
même
merci